hey everybody and welcome to an
emotional wild ride with stevo can you
believe that we made it to a hundred
episodes i'm fighting back to tears just
to think about it and this episode
really is special i've got my sister she
was the first supporter of me in this
silly career she knows so much about me
and she's gonna serve up the juice for
you man and you know what you know who's
gonna really serve up a killer deal for
you it's harry's what's harry's it's
what i use to shave my face and i love
it
i've just
gotta have it man i gotta have it on my
tour bus in my little travel toiletry
kit at home on my van oh come on dude i
don't go anywhere without harry's it's
the best shaving products you can get
and they've got the best deal for the
listeners of the wild ride podcast if
you go to harry's dot com slash stevo
and your first customer first time then
they're gonna hook you up with the
starter kit it's got the weighted
ergonomic handle the five blade razor
the cool travel cover the foaming shave
gel with aloe that starter kit is a 13
value and they're gonna give it to you
for just three bucks if you go to
harry's dot-com slash stevo i love it
i've been using them for years even
for
what almost two years before they got in
business with me i'm a proud customer of
harry's and i want you to be too so go
to harrys.como
now let's get into it
i'm so proud of you thank you cindy one
all right well i'm gonna keep that in
ladies and gentlemen my sister
cynthia claire glover oh [ __ ] now
it's funny the first thing i said at
work is um
it's not cynthia it's cindy i only get
called cynthia when i'm in trouble it
started with mom cynthia claire glover
you get down here right this minute
which i didn't hear very often and so it
was very very distressing
um
or the you know when you get pulled over
cynthia claire glover do you know how
fast you were going so that's my i'm in
trouble name like when when when
everything is good i'm cindy so let's
just start right there speaking of names
that uh we don't like
my message oh stephen gilchrist glover
well my middle name is gilchrist and uh
it's very english of you right it was my
grandfather's middle name
but at some point i want to say i was
like well how old would i have been like
seven or eight
maybe a tad younger because it was
connecticut and and cindy started
calling me gilly
and like says hey gilly and i don't even
know why but i was so upset about that
and because i was upset
cindy wouldn't hammer it a little harder
yeah not the same i had so few levers
that you know when i found one not that
cindy was particularly mean but that
that's probably the the meanest you ever
were
i'll take that yeah that's pretty good
yeah that's great gilly gilly gilly
and then later when you were about
12 and i was 15
it became apparent that at some point in
the not very distant future you were
going to physically get bigger than me
and my days of being able to sit on you
and beat you up if needed
were numbered so i was gonna need the
psychological advantage
since the physical edge was rapidly
evaporating and i think that's probably
about the time i started calling you
squirt which you didn't mind and it
became your tag you spray painted it on
the side of the building at the
university of miami and put it on your
skateboards and you know
um and i still call you squirt and to my
kids you know sometimes your uncle
squirt but um the uh
yeah that was that would that replaced
gilly
they got to see their uncle squirt last
night
man bravo yeah last night i was
mortified well i mean whatever i wasn't
mortified but but it was definitely like
there was sensitivity to the fact that
my sister was watching footage of me
ejaculating on camera what about your
name i had seen it before
shielded cass for two decades
but she's 20 and last night she you know
both at the premiere and last night she
saw rather a lot of her uncle's penis
yeah next to cindy when they put the
bees on your dick and then like oh no
yeah
the bucket list sure is a little bit
more aggressive than jackass
um but yeah so um i maybe would like
what what to talk about i mean there's
so there's so much um
i i want to thank you as i always have
for
being
the earliest supporter of my
choice to try to become a professional
idiot
like uh really cindy was was behind me
before anybody else was when was that
choice made i made that choice
officially in 1993
when i dropped out of the university of
miami i was couch surfing for three
years and ended up moving in with my
sister in albuquerque new mexico
and uh she she was behind me what was
that what was the choice to become a
professional idiot i well i was gonna be
i was trying to become a
famous stuntman
by videotaping
idiotic stunts with my home video camera
there was no precedent for that cindy
was a supporter she let me live in her
house and
she found out about to
tell that a little bit about how you
feel about the way i
uh tell the story of
you taking a dump and
is that accurate it is
um so in albuquerque i was the city hall
reporter and um we had a little bureau
downtown separate from the main
city hall or sorry the main newspaper
office
and um there were five of us in this
downtown bureau uh and the albuquerque
tribune albuquerque journal are the
albuquerque yeah the tribune was the
enemy that was that was the rival um but
uh
we had this bathroom and um one of the
the reporters there had put like a
little table with some flowers in it and
you know it was it was pretty cozy
because there were just five of us in
this office and we had like a
lounging chair and a couple of other
things and there were some magazines and
there was a trivia book in the bathroom
and this was before cell phones this
would have been 1995
96 96 okay so cell phones weren't really
you know a thing you didn't take your
phone into the bathroom with you and it
actually would have been i moved to
albuquerque in 96 but this would have
been 97. okay
um
so
you know
in the era before cell phones if you
were
planning on spending more than just a
couple of seconds in the bathroom you
might pick up whatever was lying around
and so i often would read some of the
trivia things um
just
passing time
and
one of the little items was what is um
you know one of the only universities or
colleges in the country that doesn't
have any tuition
um and is statistically harder to get
into than harvard or maybe that's
something you came up with later but um
and it was the ringling brothers barnum
bailey clown college in sarasota
that had auditions
you know throughout the year for each
class and then um didn't charge any
tuition
and i thought reeling brothers barnaba
bailey clown college like that could be
a way to legitimize all like that could
be awesome
because at the time you had
signed up you'd been in and out of
school but i'd encouraged you to um sign
up at unm and you took a gymnastics
class yeah and that was when and you
really wanted the standing back flip and
you worked really hard on it and you got
it
um
and uh you'd always done a couple of bar
tricks for beer because you know
um
but you went to
the uh we found out that um i did some
research i found out that there were
auditions coming up and
yeah you tell the story better than i do
well i remember it was the very same day
you took the dump
it all started when i you know yeah when
my sister was taking a dump and uh
i came home from school i was in in the
university and i came home there was a
note on the kitchen table that said
ringling brothers barnum and bailey
clown college apparently tuition is free
if you can get in and i still saved that
note i still have it and um so i i i
okay well this is cool and i called up
the the phone number and
um
i think it was just a voicemail that
said uh i was getting ready to tell him
oh how i'm a rad stuntman
it was just a voicemail saying if you
want an audition schedule then leave uh
your address and so i left the address
and
didn't think about it too much and then
uh when the
audition schedule came in the mail i had
been
i wasn't home i i was on ryan simon
eddie's floor barfing all over his
carpet like with alcohol poisoning i've
seen the footage i think of that yeah
the one where i'm at the top of the
stairs
and so i was very hungover when i came
home to find this piece of mail for me
with uh you know the audition schedule
and i looked down it and it said
albuquerque you know for the class of
1998 there's a cut-off line
i saw albuquerque saw it's not for the
next it's not until next year so
whatever and i just was hung over and i
just put it back down i went to go smoke
pot at my buddy's house
and then when i came home i walked in
cindy was very stern
she says how are you getting to denver
by monday
she insisted yeah why because you were
such a good roommate because i bought
because above the line there was an
audition for
college were you
were you before that the type of guy
to say that like because i feel like
nowadays you would have been like oh the
they're not coming to albuquerque for
another year so
i'm gonna go to denver or i'm gonna
figure out how to do it sooner you
wouldn't be just like i'll just i'll
just wait then like were you that type
of guy and is cindy kind of like when
you when he said to you
i want to be a crazy stunt man were you
kind of like well okay you're gonna have
to [ __ ] make some [ __ ] happen here
like you gotta get some skills or
something like was it kind of a
you know what i'm saying our dad um
in his youth
sold encyclopedias or something and um
he raised us there were a couple of
quirks in how we were raised it might
not be everybody's experience and um
one of the things that he learned that
he passed on to us is that no is a
request for further
information no just means they obviously
didn't understand the first time so you
need to rephrase i love it um
you know that that
was one of the things we learned so um
we
you know the other thing is it doesn't
really matter what you're gonna do but
if you're gonna do it
rock you know like go balls out do
really do it hard um
we don't really half-ass anything
um
you know if you're going to
be a sucker who loves animals
[ __ ] adopt a bajillion of them you
know
um whatever it is
do it
well um
because
doing anything half-assed is just
defensive
sure yeah so
um so when steve came to you and was
like i want to be this famous stunt man
like i knew you were supportive about
the sort of what was it
yeah right if that's what you want
okay cool what are we gonna do about it
right um how can i help you because that
was you know that was always
yeah i remember one of the first things
when we moved to albuquerque i had just
dialed in the standing back flip
and i had taken to pouring alcohol
rubbing alcohol on my skin and lighting
it and using it in my hand as a fire
breathing torch so once i was pouring
rubbing alcohol on my skin and lighting
it on fire i decided oh man i'm going
big i'm gonna
pour rubbing alcohol all over my entire
body
and light my whole body on fire and then
do a standing back flip you know i've
smeared vaseline all over to try to make
it a little bit safer
and and i chose for my first time doing
this stunt which i pictured being a
pretty big one
uh when the radio station
announced that they're holding a freak
of nature contest so i called up the
radio station said i'm gonna
douse my entire body with
rubbing alcohol light off my whole body
on fire to a standing backflip and i
guess the 90s were a different time in
albuquerque because they were like right
on you're in you're you know yeah
everybody's like yeah like right on
you're in done
and uh my sister was there holding the
wet blanket to wrap around me to put me
out wow
i think i've also seen footage i'm
pretty sure it's you filming cindy comes
in wakes you up
walks you outside and you just do a
backflip in the front yard it's like it
felt like this is kind of like a ritual
of like
wake me up in the morning i'll just do a
backflip first thing or something like
that backflip in and of itself just to
backflip on its own was kind of like
whatever and so i was just looking for
ways to make it cooler so like light my
whole body on fire and i thought what if
like i said cindy like come in you know
before i'm awake like film me sleeping
wake me up and and say okay do a
backflip
and uh
yeah i should do something with that
footage i had my teeth all broken and
[ __ ] yeah but yeah that was that was my
sister nobody else was like you know
stoked to help me like and then after
clown college two you were like doing a
bunch of clown tricks there's like an
hour of footage where you're trying to
get this one trick right and you're like
okay like you hear you just being like
so supportive but also just sitting
there the whole time filming it is like
a task you know
yeah and and and because cindy
was
so instrumental you know so like like
without cindy's support i never would
have gone to clown college you know i'd
who knows you know i mean i probably
would have gotten somewhere but
cindy uh was was in my corner and uh and
and i'm just forever grateful for that
yeah i really really genuinely am
forever grateful for that i'm just so
proud of you like seriously for years
we knew there were only three options
you were going to be famous incarcerated
or dead
nothing else was even on the table like
there was never going to be a straight
job where you wear a tie and sit at a
desk
that was that was that's not gonna
happen
um incarceration was a distinct
possibility um as we know from all of
the mugshots that we've tried to track
down over the years
yeah
here and there um
and um
you did not protect your life as well as
i would have liked um but you know
certainly post sobriety
i mean i still have that pit in my
stomach for worrying about you and
that's
you know just hasn't gone away um and we
have our deal where you don't tell me
about the really scary stuff until after
you've survived it and i'm grateful
um we started that when you were
the spokesman for snowshoes and you were
gonna get the alligator to chomp your
foot wearing the skate shoe
the burden of knowing that that was
gonna happen it was like a small
alligator
whatever um that's not a bad idea dude
you know with my snow shoes like
yeah darn good shoe
but um but yeah i mean we've um
we've had each other's backs
since we were tiny i mean um
you know i often joke uh
i'm a glover not a fighter but the very
first fight i ever got into was
defending steve um he was about five i
was about eight and this overweight
eleven-year-old kid in our neighborhood
was smearing snow in his face
and i
i don't know if you remember this this
was in connecticut
um it was winter
the kid was a bully
i'm sure he has a tragic backstory that
i was unaware of at the time his name
was jeffrey um
but uh he was like making fun of you and
smearing snow in your face you were five
he was like 11. and i gave him a bloody
nose nice and he didn't mess with you
again
um
but we moved around a lot and um
you know i think i think
um
when that happens you're always the new
kid so you became like the show off in
class clown and i just found the smart
kids like where are my people um
but uh
we only had each other as playmates you
know it wasn't like
eventually you would have your friends
and i would have my friends but every
couple of years there would be this
starting over and it was just us and
yeah um
we recently had
like what for me was a really intense
experience um
i
was sitting down with a
writer from gq
who was writing a story
for uh
the gq website on me and
i was trying to articulate to him how
intense the alcoholism on our mom's side
of the family was and and i was like i
was getting ready to tell him the
stories i understood it but i was like
you know
let me call up cindy and
see so i got cindy on the phone i had
her own speaker phone the the reporter
has his tape recorder out and i'm like
cindy
like uh
am i right in remembering that our
grandma's second husband died in her
apartment and like she sat there and
drank with the body until she was like
out of alcohol and then
and then like dealt with the situation
cindy said no i do not believe that's
the case
but
what was really just a call about that
one quick question turned into like a
half an hour
uh
like of just being on the speakerphone
with the and the the reporter wrote
about it in the story saying he felt
like he was eavesdropping but then he
thought like well hold on a second this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like yeah he knew i was
here yeah yeah yeah like he wrote that
really masterfully well too but um
i i was saying to cindy that
she did everything right when we were
kids i did everything wrong
that i was just like a a [ __ ] up and
like you know
and and cindy said
cincinnati told the story about when our
mom suffered an aneurysm and how
and it was just like
it it
it it
kind of shocked my system you know she
she described me in a way that
tell the story
i mean let's just start with you being
the [ __ ] up like that is just not at all
how i remember it ever
um
but uh when we were growing up
mom and dad used to have a lot of like
dinner parties and stuff
and um
i guess because they were bored or
whatever you know where does balling
having your kids perform tricks to
entertain your guests is apparently like
was a thing
and so um and and dad being a
businessman you know he would give steve
a buck to do a hundred push-ups
um they were like they were they were i
don't know what i wish there was video
of that happening because and i would
get a buck to either sing don't cry for
me argentina from evita or um tomorrow
from annie
um sometimes if they were all in the
backyard where we had a pool you know
i'd get a buck for a hundred laps
whatever it was i mean
this was entertainment you remember this
right absolutely yeah um
but uh we were certainly like growing up
you
your athleticism
like they dad and mom mom and dad
actually went to your little league
games they didn't really go to any of my
gymnastics
not a particularly good athlete didn't
matter you were an enthusiastic athlete
um and you guys had that bonding like as
a family we went to some miami dolphins
games and i always brought my nancy drew
book
and so
they'd be like watching the game and mom
and dad would place bets with ted toby
ferrani i want to put a nickel on
whatever it was all by phone back in the
day and um
there was a code i just remember it was
ted toby for ronnie i guess toby
referred ted to the bookie ronnie and um
you'd put a nickel or a dime like 500 or
a thousand on whatever game and and i
had learned about the point spread but
you guys had that our parents had like
like four [ __ ] tvs set up in the
living room because they had to be
watching all four games because they
were betting on all four wow i mean they
were gnarly they were better too
they absolutely i mean they weren't like
games not definitely not gambling
addicts but it's kind of made it more
fun but yeah i mean but this is how
people entertain themselves you know
like yeah life was a little different
before netflix and chill or you know
before internet people still gamble on
games i think a good amount did your dad
still gamble on i don't think dad maybe
he does maybe he does no i don't think
so
at the football games cindy's reader and
nancy drew books and i got the
binoculars just looking at the
cheerleaders
i was you know people there's that joke
where people say you know i'm like a
football widow or whatever i was a
football orphan
like my my parents and my brother had
this thing
that i just kind of wasn't a part of i
was long for the ride so um you were you
know it was almost like in that show
matilda where they're like what's wrong
with her you know why can't you get with
the program um
but it's funny because i was a teacher
for 10 years
um career 2.0 and i remember saying you
know my c students
my a students are going to be working
for my c students because the a students
you know they get told to do something
unreasonable or whatever and they just
like knuckle down and and you know grind
it through and get it done and the c
students are like what the [ __ ] is this
i'm not doing that my time is way more
valuable than this
wow i gotta find somebody to do it for
me or how can i like half-ass it or
cheat or
you know game the system or just do the
bare minimum so i can get back to what i
really want to do um and growing up you
know you were the c student and there i
was like sweating bullets doing what i
was told to be a good girl
and steve
totally from the get-go you could see
first of all he wasn't going to be
working a straight job with the suit and
tie
but also
you were not going to be the grunt
you know grinding away at somebody
else's direction
um the whole management potential was
there from the get-go um we had uh
a um a couple of fruit trees in our
backyard in miami
and um
dad
you know at one point i'd ask for a
raise in my allowance and dad pointed to
the backyard he said see those that's
the money tree
because it would get inconvenient when
when they were dropping fruit and so i
used to take steve around with me and
we'd knock on the doors and he was
younger and cuter so i would make him
say
you know it's like
three lemons for a quarter or you know
three avocados for a buck whatever it
was at the time i'm sure it was less but
um he was younger and cuter but um so
first of all i don't think you were
always a [ __ ] up um even though you did
get in trouble a lot more than i did but
you didn't care so it was um
you know for me if they said i'm
disappointed in you i was like crushed
for you you're like all right yeah
that's your choice did you though have
like
like a
party phase of your life like did you
struggle with drinking or drugs oh yeah
for as much as my sister drank yeah she
wasn't really a partier but i'll tell
you where the party is at these days
it's in my socks drawer thanks to stance
because
why have the boring same old thing going
on all the time when you can change it
up and have fun
have your ankles and your legs dressed
up like tupac if you want god the
creativity coming out of stance is
endless the comfort is unmatched and
it's just so much fun having different
pairs of socks for different occasions
man i'm telling you plus it's not just
socks anymore they're killing it so much
they're spreading into
sweatpants joggers shirts
hoodies hats and more and i'm telling
you you gotta get in on this man it's at
stance
stance.com
and if you use the promo code stevo
you're gonna get 15
off your first order do yourself a favor
and go to stance.com just to see how
crazy
the variety
of creative options is you're going to
fall in love with so many of their
designs and you'll be so glad to have 15
off your order at stance.com
if you use the promo code stevo at
checkout your feet are gonna love the
way you feel and everyone's gonna be
blown away by how dope you are so
stance.com promo code stevo now let's
talk about drinking
definitely um
but i consider myself 15 years smarter
than steve because i got sober for the
first time at age 19.
um sober before i got legal and steve
didn't really you know get the message
till he was 34. that's what you were
drinking like so much in high school
you're like and you quit drinking at 19.
like
like a closet by myself reclusive like
secret drinker pass out at home yeah it
was not a bar scene kind of drinking
right but um it was definitely a [ __ ]
but no back to your point back to your
point about like um
no i was not i believe that
for both of us
steve's enough of that for both of us
but um when our mom first had our brain
hemorrhage or her brain hemorrhage
um we got the call
i want to say it was like 6 45 on a
saturday morning um and it was her
ex-husband who she had been reconciling
with and the message was she'd had a
brain hemorrhage she was in intensive
care she might not survive the night get
down here stat
we were in albuquerque she was in boca
raton florida
steve had been partying the night before
and had crashed where he landed
i called all of his bros and had them
like hunt him down and then i was in bed
with a stripper and there was a knock at
the window and it was my buddy ron burns
he's like you gotta go
i uh meanwhile while his skate buddies
were tracking him down i was booking
flights um arranging for my little
sister in the big brothers big sisters
program to watch my dogs because i had
two dogs um and uh you know telling work
i was gonna be out
and we were at the airport by 8 15
um and on a flight
but
the way it has always worked in a crisis
is i get very wrapped up in the doing
and researching you know as long as my
brain is working or my hands are working
i'm okay
once we got on the plane
the reality of oh my god you know our
mom who is 51 might die
and and there was like two and a half
hours maybe three hours from albuquerque
to my to uh west palm beach
where there was just nothing to do and
that's when i fell apart and steve put
his arm around me and he was okay like
he totally
took over on the plane
and he was the the comforting calming
you know presence and i was the wreck
whose brain was spinning in a million
directions
with all of the what-ifs and the regrets
and the fear and the anxiety and and all
of that and then the plane landed and we
switched roles again and you know i'm
getting us from the airport to the car
rental you know and getting us into the
the car and calling the hospital and
getting the status updates and and stuff
like that we got to the hospital
and um
we had rushed so hard to arrive and then
once you arrive and we saw her and she
was all
hooked up and it was it was
horrifying the the most disturbing
sight i've ever seen was this expression
on mom's face when we first got to her
in her hospital bed
it uh
it haunts me to this day she was almost
exactly my age when this happened um we
just recently passed the milestone
um where she was
51 and four months when she had her
brain hemorrhage i am now 51 and five
months old wow
um and it feels so weird like i am now
having more
like i've passed the amount of active
time that she got like she lived another
five years
but in a greatly incapacitated way
so i'm now kind of older than she was
which is is weird and i still don't feel
nearly nearly as grown up as mom and dad
always seemed
right yeah i always heard steve talk
about your mommy
besides the parties and the the family
the dinners and all that what kind of
person was she i mean i i don't know too
much about her dad was so successful and
and like you know this
super driven motivated businessman and
really like uh
like good good at life but he wasn't
good at like social people he's
emotionally defective like
he's just a [ __ ] straight c he's a
robot
we love our robot but you know like
emotionally he's missing a few
like
lines of programming or code because um
he has always needed people to explain
you know chalkboard and pointer style
but um
that diverges from the story
right right but but we maintain that mom
was way smarter than dad way funnier
than dad and way cooler
but also you know kind of fragile
in her way but definitely smarter cooler
more social
um
but
i don't know um when we got back to the
um when we got to the hotel or sorry to
the hospital
and mom was there and she was all hooked
up
um
we were allowed to see her very briefly
but icu is
there a lot of rules
and um
the uh we went out to the waiting room
and i was just like sitting and waiting
not my strong suit we had visited mom a
few months earlier and she had bought a
computer that was still in the box at
her house that had not been plugged in
yet
and so that first night we
negotiated that steve was going to stay
and sleep on the floor of the hospital
waiting room and i was going to go back
to mom's house plug in the computer and
start researching everything there was
to know you know 10 years of the journal
of the american medical association the
neurological association the state of
the art for you know the googly amy
coiling procedures and transcranial
doppler radar and and what we needed you
know where were the centers of
excellence for a brain hemorrhage you
know a subarachnoid hemorrhage and and
all of that and so i spent all night
reading
medical journals and reaching out to
anybody i knew
including our dad who might have you
know who played golf with doctors who
might have connections
and um
steve held down the fort
and of course you know because we're
glovers we've never met a crisis we
can't sleep through you know
when the going gets tough the tough take
naps um
it's a it's a family saying like that's
not true
for the win i didn't realize naps are
survival like um we map like champs
but steve you know stayed there
i could not have left and done all of
that research if he hadn't been able to
stay
and then dave you know we we transferred
her we made decisions and even though i
was on all of the paperwork as the
official decision maker the durable
power of attorney and all of that
because having only two children
she chose the slightly more responsible
one the older slightly more responsible
one to
put down on the list but we had a deal
you know we could tune out the entire
world her sister was saying pull the
plug pull the plug i'm like no no that's
just not a decision that
that was ever to be made because there
was brain activity but
we could tune out all the noise as long
as we could look at each other and look
in the mirror and be okay with whatever
we were deciding and we were making
big scary decisions well right because
she was in boca raton and the boca raton
hospital did not have the capability to
do the procedure that would have been
required to save her they said however
to get her
to
miami where they can do the procedure
that could save her she might not
survive the ride
it was against medical advice there was
a very arrogant doctor who was the first
one who said that he didn't recommend
doing surgery
that you just you know let nature take
its course or let whatever's going to
happen happen
and
i had asked him about all of these
state-of-the-art you know the googly-edy
coiling procedure and all of that and if
they had a transcranial doppler to
monitor the pressure in her brain and he
said you know i went to medical school
so you wouldn't have to
and um he said if you decide to
transport her by ambulance to miami to
jackson memorial medical center
affiliated with the university of miami
where they could do you know the
top-notch surgeons could do this
it's on you if she dies because like the
bumping in the car right over there
might like do something with yeah the
guy the guy was a [ __ ] and like we
were
we um we
looked at each other and we've always
kind of said in our family that if there
is a chance at like quality of life yeah
if if there's like a guarantee of of
low quality of life but you'll go for a
long time or you can take a risk but it
might actually greatly improve things
we've always said you know take the risk
yeah the ambulance side was a no-brainer
it was not a no-brainer at the time i uh
but i could not have made that decision
that that might have killed her but
might have saved her if we hadn't done
it together
not a no-brainer but it was the decision
it's what we knew she would have wanted
and but i we made it together which is
what was okay um and then
day's turn you know she survived but
there were complications days turned
into months
how many brain surgeries
two two brain surgeries but she was on a
ventilator um for four months and then
she was weaned off the ventilator and
then she was released to my care which
is a whole another story but
while she was in this nursing home um
she went from the icu to the regular
hospital to the hospital that
specializes in ventilators vencor
where to get weaned off of the
ventilator and then to a nursing home
and then home so there were a few step
down phases
in the nursing home or maybe it was the
ventilator hospital there was this nurse
who was really rough
changing
mom's diaper you know she had a catheter
a feeding tube
she was in bed they tend to keep
patients sedated when they're on the
ventilator so they don't fight with it
and this woman
i wanted to rip her throat out i wanted
to stab her eyes i you know i may be a
glover not a fighter but i just you know
she was manhandling my mom like a sack
of potatoes i wanted her fired i wanted
to like destroy her i was so
emotional and angry and protective and
here's my helpless mom and i am in
charge you know i am her protector and
this woman is just like rolling her over
and like like she is some sort of sack
of of grain
and um steve was with me and and i was
ready to
just go off and he said oh no since
uh-uh
because you know what's gonna happen
like you're going to rat out this nurse
who is
probably doesn't give a [ __ ]
and she's gonna get really pissed and
resentful and the minute we're gone
she's gonna take it out on mom let me
handle it and this is where steve's like
schmoozy
you know
teachers
who were always saying you know like
he's like i'll show her a back flip
she's gonna love it
steve just always kind of charmed his
way out of trouble i mean eve frick even
in jail like
where
being as adorable as you are you
certainly could have had a negative
experience but instead you entertained
everybody and became their you know best
bro and the most interesting like you've
just always had people skills that i
might have lacked and um
so you charmed that nurse you you talked
to her you found out about her family
about
you know you thanked her
damned if you didn't become her like bff
and
bring we brought her some chocolates or
something or brought the whole nursing
staff chocolates so that mom would get
you know treated
really nicely because
he he totally you know his diplomacy was
so superior to my
like
grizzly bear protective
you know roll reversal mama bear cub
kind of
thing
and um
that happened you know a few different
times but
um
between the two of us you know there
came a time after mom was released home
to my care
where i was pretty good at you know
hiring the nurse's aides and
managing her medication schedule and her
appointments and all of the daily care
and the feedings and how many calories
we're going to go in and and um getting
like the wheelchair van and the ramp for
the house because there were a couple of
little like step up step down situations
and steve was just not like good at any
of that all of that adulting stuff
um
but he was um like super supportive um
of me for sure
and um
at some point it was like look we don't
both have to be here
like this doesn't have to clip both of
our wings you know i'm good i'd gotten a
job at the newspaper um and we'd moved
officially into her house
and um there was the cruise ship
opportunity out of miami right
i was pretty clear that i wasn't going
to add any value by
just being a loser and eating the food
you know
you were never a loser though you made
her laugh like when you got [ __ ] and
[ __ ] tattooed on your knuckles and stuff
like the last time she ever laughed
i don't think that's necessary
and that was at the end okay it was
october of 2003 when i got [ __ ] and
[ __ ] tattooed on my knuckles
and i flew home i flew home and she was
in bed with the do not resuscitate order
and it was the end did your mom ever see
you on tv
not not
um
not
no jackass had had been picked up well
no no 1998
mom's aneurysm was october 10th of 1998.
but she passed away in on november 7th
of 2003
and by 2003
cassie had been born you know like a
jackpot i'm sure but mom mom was never
uh
like
she was less coherent by the time jackie
she was she was it was after her
aneurysm yeah that all that happened
and before
you know i would show my mom yeah before
her aneurism i would show her my stunt
videos and stuff and she was just like
she was never once like concerned
like for my safety it wasn't like oh my
god like you're going to get hurt but
she was just like how is there money in
this
how was there like that was her only
concern
it was that she's just like well you
know like show me the money you know
like where's that like uh like you don't
have a pot to piss in like like i'm not
impressed by your your stupid [ __ ]
vhs tape
because you're broke and you're sleeping
in my [ __ ] house and you have no
money and like
you're a slob and you have bad breath
ouch
no no no no no that's cindy would she
have said that or not she wouldn't she
totally would say you know don't be a
loser
don't be you know don't end up she did
she saw that tom cruise jerry maguire
and that was her thing show me the money
but growing up like it was
always i was more like dad
you were more like mom
and
in some ways we grew up with different
parents like we're only three and a half
years apart in age
but
the break the you know their marriage
kind of falling apart
happened when you were in high school
um after i had already moved out
and um and
when i was growing up they were super
strict and you know there's also sexism
involved
daughter versus son but um
my you know from my grades to my curfews
and all of that everything was very like
uptight and strict and by the time steve
hit high school
dad was away a lot and uh you know we
discovered later why um and mom
would you know like to get into the
liquor
she would
kind of check out while he was gone and
then clean up a little when he came back
you know before he came back but
steve was
ready you know able to run buck wild un
you know completely unsupervised i was
going full pippy longstock
i was in london that was england yeah
yeah
so in in that respect we grew up with
different parents but um
mom
like you smoked weed with mom
i did struggle and you drank with mom
and i never did either of those things
and you used to tell dirty jokes like
the one about the cheetos
when i when i smoked weed with mom like
she was drunk at the time and like i
don't remember that fun it was i was
just like here she was drunk and i was
like here mom here's a joint she's like
you know like it wasn't rad like there
was nothing cool about that and um you
know like
because
mom
was that way she she really
cared about
how uh we would reflect on her
appearances mattered a lot like we
always clean up the house before guests
came we're going to have company not
like friends are coming we're going to
have company
put on a nice shirt and like yeah elbows
off the table right and when when they
had company meaning like they're they're
like you know showing off for their
friends
they would have these like dinner
parties their friends would come over
and it would just be a
brag fest it would just be like what
like trump oh well you know we just
bought this or like we just have this or
our
kid just got into this university and it
was just a [ __ ] just as a kid we were
able to realize like this is kind of
weird for sure it wasn't just an
obnoxious pissing match is that why you
don't like the like you don't want to
buy a [ __ ] ferrari or something right
now you hate flashing it thanks you're
not flashy at all i don't like
flashiness and and as i grew up
you know cindy moved out of the house
when i was 12.
and then no i did not yeah
15. i was not 15. i was you went to
boarding school when i was 16. i was a
year i graduated from high school at 17.
so it was 16 to 17. seventh grade is
when you're 12 and my birthday's in june
so like
i think it was eighth grade but i was i
was i was in
because i was a day student at havergill
when you were at baby bayview glasgow it
doesn't matter but our house got bigger
and bigger as we grew up you know dad
became more and more successful as we
grew up in the house and the house got
bigger and i was like embarrassed of the
house
i might have felt uncomfortable about
the way my house got bigger as i grew up
but i am not uncomfortable about the way
my wiener gets bigger and harder when i
use blue chew tablets i said it okay if
i'm getting ready to take lux to bone
town then about a half an hour
beforehand you know it i'm chewing up a
bluetooth tablet why because it's
delicious it's got the same active
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except it only cost a fraction of the
price and
when we're ready to go to bone town man
my blue chew tablets make it count so
much fun if you've ever wondered whether
or not trying bluetooth tablets is fun i
can assure you it is lux loves it so
much sometimes she'll leave one out on
the table
on a plate she'll say honey i made you
dinner i'll come upstairs and see a
bluetooth tablet and i know it's going
down
yeah man but
maybe you're wondering don't i need a
prescription for that well yeah but you
don't have to go to the doctor's office
for some awkward in-person visit hell no
you go to bluetooth.com and you consult
with one of their medical providers
right there on the site super fast super
easy and when you use the promo code
stevo get this they'll they will send
you an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets for free
all you got to pay is five bucks for
shipping so
i'm telling you it's a blast
it's easy and it's free all you got to
pay is five bucks for shipping what are
you waiting for get over to bluechew.com
use the pro promo code stevo
watch your wiener get bigger and harder
and use it for good yeah dude
bluetooth.com
now let's get back to the house
and
um in high school
if i was if i overslept or just was
running late in the morning and wasn't
in time to skateboard to school
i would be forced to
catch a ride with dad in his chauffeur
driven car
and dad would be in the back seat of his
car with his chauffeur driving him
reading his newspaper
and i would
ride shotgun
and then when we pulled the school and i
got out i would hug the driver because i
didn't want anybody knowing i'd been
chauffeur driven to school wow
i would just talk to the driver be like
yeah you know and i wouldn't even
acknowledge i just hug the driver and
get out and like uh
you know i'd want them to drop me off
like a little further down the block
and and and i was always looking to be
from a pretty young age like i didn't
like having
kids over to our house because i didn't
want people to see
mom didn't want kids over um like it was
in my parenting life my house is the
house that every teenager within about
five miles just migrates to
and um
it's an open door you know we had a
fingerprint lock for a long time and
they're about 20 different fingers on
in the fingerprint lock um and uh
you know it's it's totally the house in
the neighborhood that all the kids hang
out at but when we were growing up
partly because of mom's drinking and her
you know image sensitivity and what the
kids might say to their parents or
whatever
it was very
you know like we didn't have people over
and if you asked to have a sleepover it
was a big deal because mom would be
weighing like oh crap okay i'm gonna
have to cook dinner i'm going to have to
you know tidy up there's no upside it's
all downstairs
and so we just knew we kind of knew
better than to ask and i think that's
really common with
adult children of alcoholics when you
grow up that way it's fine that you
think of it that way because for me i
just didn't want to be at home i was
like like whose house like whose house
can i go to today yeah and it was pretty
much always abdullah's house
but yeah and but the thing is that you
know that's just very much
like like mom and dad
for better or worse and you know i love
my dad you know i love my mom so i'm not
talking [ __ ] on anybody but the fact is
they thought that because they had money
that made them better than people
we are the apple did not fall that far
for either of us because although we're
not materialistic in that way
um
we did sort of learn that like lines are
for losers who can't figure out like a
way to avoid waiting in the line we're
not like british or canadian where we
queue up you know we definitely look for
the angles and and things like speed
limits or no trespassing signs are
because you know some people aren't as
smart as we are and need like to be
protected from injury those are for the
dumb sheep
for people who aren't aware of their
limits but if you actually have physical
prowess or skills and and you are aware
of the risks and can do the cost-benefit
analysis then go proceed at your own
risk like it's a suggestion the rules
and the speed limits are a suggestion
that are very helpful for people who
might not be as smart as we are for sure
yeah
like he'll give me you know like five
things to do and it's like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the minutia of why or
why not this person said i can't he's
like is it done yet or is it not like
that you know i just i figured out shady
scott's just gonna make it happen yeah
it doesn't care the progress bottom line
is great when are we going
and that's that's all dad and and the
the social you know the the charming
holding court you know telling stories
like that's all mom
and um you know people think that
we're so different um and in some ways
we are like i i was a high school
teacher for 10 years and i would
remember um for 10 years i crushed
dreams because there was always a new
kid who kind of didn't know and they'd
be like dude we got glover for history
this is going to be totally rad and then
a week later they'd be like wow this is
not that right
yeah do you do a lot of kids like they
do you have to say like yes my brother
is stevo let's move on like do you have
to kind of make an announcement i'm not
a teacher anymore like
i'm on my fourth career but um the uh
in all those years of teaching people
would you know the the kids who didn't
really know glover's reputation
um would be so stoked like you know
jackass history
and then
whoa yeah um but it's funny there used
to be this weird thing they'd do at
school at our school it was a private
school where they'd come back from
christmas break on a thursday the public
schools didn't come back until monday
and the students had class like thursday
and friday after being off for you know
almost a month
and the edict from the administration
was
you had to teach something meaningful
even though half of the kids were going
to be absent
you couldn't just you know show a video
you had to do something meaningful but
there was no point in starting the new
chapter
because come monday you'd have to
re-teach it all
and the um i taught juniors and seniors
and they'd be like way too cool to show
up on that stupid thursday and friday
you know
and um so there were a couple of years
where i brought stephen as a guest
lecturer but i didn't tell anybody you
know he he taught my economics a couple
of sections of my economics class i went
in with dad yeah dad and i taught
economics
so you taught the curriculum like that's
you wore dad's murisol golf shirt you
know like the um but look the funny
thing is that steve came in and um you
know this served a couple of purposes
first of all i was going to have him do
a guest lecture about the economics of
hollywood
and ha and um second of all you know
this was gonna kill time because half
the kids were gonna be absent but
on monday morning the kids who missed it
would be like oh
man
and you know that would show them to
blow off my class there you go and so
steve came in to you know a slightly
lower census than usual
but i had him talk about the economics
of hollywood
and so here you know he's
talking about legitimate you know the
mistakes he didn't make with his money
um
how you know dad had taught him about
all these football players who made
millions and then blew it and and not
how to not be that guy but also he would
talk about how he barely made any money
the first season of jackass
and um the importance of having a good
vocabulary and being able to read a
contract that would you know sign away
rights to
importance of having someone read your
contract for you
but you knew what the words in all media
in perpetuity meant right and that that
was not something that you particularly
wanted to sign so having a good
vocabulary comes in handy i mean being
able to hire people comes in handy
having a good lawyer comes really having
vocabulary means that you are less
likely to get ripped off and and you can
read stuff even if you you know often
choose not to at least it'll get read um
but you know you were smart enough to
get into the university of miami i think
you got you know 1250 on your sats
i think it was like 11 90. okay but i
did smoke pot immediately before
the thing is that like you're more like
me than most people realized because you
are intelligent you're articulate you
follow the news
you know
you you're definitely
in those sessions
they got to see that like there's this
persona but when steve's at home he's
not
throwing himself off buildings and
smashing his ear and stuff it's
um
that's the oh he's not jacking off out
of airplanes on his downtime
i don't
think um and then
you know the uh you would take a selfie
with every kid in the class and and that
was super cool but you had
like a teacher
in you like part you you have an ability
to communicate and educate and all of
that and
um and i think that's really cool and um
you're also i think um
more like me than people realize in that
the journalism you
my first career for eight years was as a
newspaper reporter interviewing people
and and being a journalist
and look at you like podcast 100
yeah about that you interview people
well i bored sit people down so that i
can talk at them
you don't dominate the conversation
nearly as much as you used to i still i
still
do it a lot every now and then you get
real excited it just sucks because the
more like
excited i am like the more i blow it
well especially if you know the like for
knoxville like you know him so well you
got all these stories you want him to
tell and so you're going to just tell it
to him
but then oftentimes we have someone
where you don't know them as well like
buying biolic or something and then it's
like
you know you're just asking real
questions and listening you're great
dude you're doing totally take credit
welcome for your journalism chops
i mean hey i don't i don't give myself
too much credit for for journalism i um
i
absolutely am i'm honored and grateful
for the kind words about my growth as a
podcaster and uh and i'm touched by how
big of a deal is when
there are news stories like
stemming from an episode of the wild
ride podcast
uh like that's so like you're
glowing you're beaming you're so like
and and that means the world to me i
love it i am so proud of you but you
know it's funny because if there is a
theme of this episode
it's
you not realizing or like being way
harder on yourself than i think you
should be like if i could recalibrate it
you thinking you were much more of a
[ __ ] up when you were little than i
think you ever were you thinking you
know like mom was way harsher
you didn't hear what she was saying you
know i would hear what she was saying to
her friends and she was so proud of you
and um
god we're all so proud of you i mean
there was a time
when
if we went to mcdonald's it was just
understood
that i would pay
you know i mean there didn't need to be
any conversation or anything and um
the fact just what you have done
you know there was a time when you would
have described yourself as lazy and you
work so incredibly hard at the things
that you believe in like right now
you're touring you've got the book
coming out you're doing the podcasts
you're
you know you just finished doing all of
the media for jackass forever
your schedule is insane
and that is not like the lazy slacker
pothead guy who
you know
maybe rolls out of bed to do a back flip
or you know
right a kick flip or you know something
like
i guess i'll do a skate sesh but then
i'm gonna need a nap you know like i
mean we still nap like champs but you
are um
well thank you for that and you know one
thing for that they really really mean
so much that like given how much mom
cared about appearances how much she
cared about
about wealth you know like all of these
things
um i just think mom would have loved to
have been on a red carpet
at a one of our jackass movie premieres
i think she would have been so
[ __ ] funny making fun of me
like she would have just been roasting
me for all the stuff that i was doing
but like
she would also be really really uh i
just wish that i could have had that
experience to share with mom and i also
wish
that uh we could have gotten sober
together like i wonder if if we were
in a fellowship of of uh of recovery
together if if the the abuse that led to
the
aneurysm
you know
you know um if mom and i were sober
together and like
god i wish i could have had a
relationship with her and i was both be
sober we did like she did string
together one year of sobriety at one
point and um she did like you know
drop a few
pearls of aa wisdom on you
but
there were five years
five years and one month between her
aneurysm and when she passed away
and i believe that at age 51 when she
had the aneurysm she absolutely was not
ready
um but she made a decision about four
months before she passed away
and in to the extent that she was able
to communicate i don't know if you
remember this she said no more hospitals
like she was done
she had had the um infection with the
the methicillin resistant staph
uh mrsa infection
um she was getting the vancomycin like
iv antibiotics that are super intense um
but at one point she said no more
hospitals
and she
decided like i think that at the point a
few months before she passed away
because i was always i was already
planning for another 15 years like i we
totally didn't expect her to pass away
when she did physically she was pretty
healthy even though she was disabled i
thought she was going to live another 15
years you know we were planning for that
um
but i think that at the point when she
made that decision
she knew i was going to be okay like i
had left journalism i had
was getting my teaching certificate
i had decided to become a single mom by
choice i had cassie she was
almost one and a half at that point
you
you know between famous incarcerated or
dead
jackass had been picked up by mtv the
first season
well the first movie came out in 2002
right so the first movie had happened
the the um
at that point you were now recognizable
to the point where the only place i
could take you was costco because any
where the old people didn't know you but
everywhere else
it was
pretty rough
remember how much we loved going to
costco because you could like stroll
around look at electronics and
besides an employer too
it was just not the demographic that you
had to worry about but if you lost your
computer charger and i took you to the
mall
all of a sudden these kids would just be
like texting each other and stalking us
to the food court or the elevator we
just couldn't go anywhere but at the
point that mom decided she was done
like she knew i was gonna be okay i had
cass i you know had a new career she
knew you were gonna be okay between like
famous incarcerated or dead it looked
like the needle had landed on famous
um
and uh you know as far as the things
that she would have worried about
i think she was like okay you know
they're good they're launched they're
gonna be all right
i don't have to you know stick around
um and um she made a decision and within
three months
that was that you know we got hospice
care and um we were both there but um
[Music]
she didn't
was here
yeah home hospice but she didn't
let go
until she knew you were gonna be okay
and
then
we had her ashes
sitting on the top shelf
in this closet
we had never talked about like we knew
that
as a family we're kind of not that big
on cemeteries because you're taking up
you know a plot of land that'll never be
usable for anything else
um it it seems and it's creepy
it's just you know the exact reason
steve hates ceremonies it's creepy you
know it's yeah it's it's
counterproductive it's creepy and and
and it's like an eye for an eye makes
the whole world blind you know burial
makes the whole world a cemetery so we
knew we were going to have her
we knew we were going to have a cremated
but we didn't know what to i didn't know
what to do with it with these ashes like
we didn't have like a vault or anything
she didn't have a particular place that
she loved
we didn't have
you know we've moved around so much um
growing up that it wasn't like we had
a really special place on the globe
where you could like put a push pin
and that was like our place
and so dad like it's like it had been
like a number of years the mom's ashes
were just in this closet and
our dad goes to uh
uh some psychic and i don't know where
the psychic says hey
your ex-wife
uh needs to be
set free or released or something it's
like her ashes like being in the club
her solar spirit is stuck it's closure
and that was just like kind of good
major goose pumps just saying that like
that's pretty specific you know like the
ashes like to refer to the ashes so
in december of 2011 cindy and i finally
by then you had started surfing no no no
no and
when i i i pissed somebody off really
badly when i was in rehab in
2008
i like uh it was one there was an older
guy
and we were in some group
and i was like you know
i just said for some reason in this
career i said i never want to snort
anything again in my life
except maybe a line of my mom's ashes
that's just being like what i don't even
know what the [ __ ] and this this old guy
was like very offended by that well
yeah i never actually meant to snort my
mom's ashes but in december of 2011
cindy and i had like paid for like a
a charter a charter boat i needed to
scatter her at sea yeah and it just so
happened that when a gust of wind well
yeah it was choppy seas it was windy as
hell i got in the back of the on the bed
like the bow of the boat and and throw
the ashes and the wind
[ __ ] blows her ashes into my face and
i was like
like just happy and and then i just
started laughing i was like
i just snorted my mom's lashes
would have gotten a kick out of that
yeah i mean it was sort of like a
everybody likes the ocean
no matter yeah we are you know it's a
place that we
find spiritual um and and right steve
now surfs on regularly
so this was december of 2011. i snorted
her ashes like by accident we come back
and it was just so choppy and such a
nightmare
honestly and we got back we drove
separately and we also
burned her um journals from aaa and and
her amends and and inventory and stuff
like um just kind of let her
all of that stuff go in in a bonfire and
this gnarly picture she had of her mom
all drunk and remember yeah just um but
as we we got back to the dock you know
the the um
parking lot where we went on this
charter boat i i'm sure we were in
separate cars and we drove you know back
back home as we pulled away
the only time
in my life that i can ever remember
seeing
uh
two
completely distinctly separate rainbows
like just so pronounced
and and like we drove from scattering
our ashes and i was just like looking at
these
they were huge and they were not saying
that one double rainbow you're saying a
rainbow here and then over there that's
another rainbow
like
yeah i mean they were so distinctly
separate yeah it's amazing and i i like
it
it was very impactful to me i thought
wow like
like that's a one rainbow for me and
it's one rainbow for cindy
and um it and it just so happened that
the very next month january of
2012 i uh you know i went on tour to
hawaii and like that someone's like dude
you want to go surfing i'm like dude the
last thing i want to do is go surfing
but they just i was like oh all right
and i had so much fun i had so i caught
the bug and then i caught the big net
now so we'd scatter mom in the ocean and
then from that point on
all i wanted to do was be in the ocean i
just fell in love with surfing served
all the time and whenever i was in the
ocean and saw a rainbow
like hey ma big moment yeah yeah that
was always like a big thing that's cool
but rainbows are my deal lux's thing is
is owls
owls at for lux and rainbows for me
rainbow's in the ocean
rainbows in the ocean are big time extra
epic yeah hey cindy you referenced a
dirty cheeto joke earlier and we never
got the joke and i gotta imagine
someone's sitting here thinking what's
the [ __ ] cheeto joke
um you know it's funny because our mom
had
just like with steve there's like stevo
and then there's steve
our mom had her like prim and proper
you know this is me having company
company version and then with her
friends you know a couple of sips in
she loved a dirty joke and there was
something there was one about this i
remember the cheater joke i'll tell it
to steve but
yeah this guy he goes to the doctor
everybody
right
um
and my mom and i mean everybody on my
mom's side of the family
like
like with the exception of our
generation
you know like from my mom's generation
and older
like my mom had a brother and a sister
the three siblings are all dead and all
from like
cirrhosis of the liver like like
alcohol clearly shortened their
lifespans we are seventh generation
alcoholics as far as we know um you know
it could certainly go back farther and
it's on mom's side there's there's
mental health
like uh
this is alcoholism addiction it's
depression bipolar
and mom um
and her sister
this was a joke in my first uh thing
about how while i was in clown college
my my cousin
was in mortician school
and so that's my mom and her sister and
they were having they were just getting
hammered
arguing over whose son was a bigger
loser whether it's me and clown college
are hurt you know but that's not the
cheeto joke right now i know that but
but that was i just it's a time when i
remember them laughing because that like
they were cracking themselves up like
trying to win like they were like
arguing each other like debating like no
no come on my son's a [ __ ] clown i
definitely win
yeah but i'm like my son has the hots
for dead bodies
yeah yeah
but but the cheeto joke it wasn't
necessarily that great but the guy goes
to the doctor he's like doctor like my
like i'm freaking out my [ __ ] dick
turned orange you know like i'm the
[ __ ] like you know like and the
doctor like you know runs some she's
everything's like look pretty normal you
know like there's really nothing wrong
with you like um like maybe it's like
work-related stress
and he says doctor i don't even have a
job he says well what do you do he says
sit at home and watch porno and eat
cheetos
now the reason that that
the unexpected thing is that coming out
of our mom with her hair and her
manicures and her gucci purse and her
golf shirts and her like meticulously
clean house and her mercedes like
she was such a boca babe
and yet you know these um
occasionally she you know would come out
with an unexpected profanity or an
unexpected um
yeah she definitely had like a naughty
side to her
and um she was a party girl
in her 20s
and before dad um mom and i used to
[ __ ] crack up we would laugh our
[ __ ] asses off and in the face of
like
you know
like we we could laugh when [ __ ] was not
going good what would she have thought
of the bucket list show last night
but
i think um
i am
i have the toughest time with the parts
where you're getting hurt like i don't
like the post vasectomy hanging upside
down like i don't like seeing your ear
bleeding
things things where where you are
in pain
um i absolutely hate i think she would
definitely have laughed about the um the
naughtier
everything about the
the intimacy i i think we all hate the
the urine stuff and um
mom had a little bit of germaphobia i
don't i think that you know having
trained as a nurse because when she
after she graduated from from high
school um her dad thought college was
wasted on a girl because you know
they're just going to get married and so
he wasn't willing to pay for it the only
thing that was free was nursing school
but with her nurse training it was
really hard for us to pretend to be sick
um because she was like no go to school
yeah
you're fine go to school she was
drinking and then and then she'd be like
hey let's watch tv all day but um
the
she definitely
would be aware of
in a an inflatable swimming pool full of
urine that had percolated for a while
what
the load of bacteria and stuff is in
there like that would not have been her
jam at all um but of course she had been
proud of you i mean people
cheering your name like your your name
on the marquee
all of those people standing in line and
just like thrilled and you making their
day
um
your people skills your ability to like
entertain and hold court and make people
laugh definitely didn't come from dad
your business sense your ability to hawk
the merch
did but
there is a direct line between your
theatricality and showmanship and and
warmth and charisma
and mom
and um
of course she'd have been proud like if
you you've got to know that in your soul
and in your heart because for sure i i
do and i just wish that i could have
shared i know and part of what has
driven you to be so successful and part
of what drives you to work so hard
is a bit of insecurity and you know
that's not the worst thing in the world
it moves a lot of people i certainly
have my own share of you know trying to
get dad's approval and stuff like that
but um
you are too hard on yourself
because
she was
proud of you already
um
showed off
you know and um
she was also very proud about how
handsome you are oh yeah wow oh yeah i
don't remember that
i know she was proud about herself being
attractive
yeah she was very pretty from the photos
yeah she really was
um
did did you know i should i should admit
this maybe
that um
there's a
when i was in
canada doing stand-up and all just about
every time that i went to canada and did
stand-up i would say hey guys you know
like uh i'm canadian because my mom was
born in canada she actually went to high
school with tom green's mom
but my mom was a way bigger [ __ ]
and like
i know i'm just kidding whatever you
know i'm just kidding your image
conscious mom would not i haven't been
stoked on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hated but it was clear that i was
making a joke yeah you know clear that i
was making a joke and she definitely had
bigger tits
she did she might have mentioned if you
got it flaunt it yeah a couple of times
and wasn't mom pretty proud that uh the
the first day she um
i went on a date with dad that she was
like rushing for
my previous date or something
she was definitely not that stoked on
him um but you know she gave him another
chance
on her what's so great she said no
what's so great about
mom
uh wasn't jumping on
the bandwagon of dad's success like that
they were she was in debt when she
married when they got married like that
like dad became successful after they
got together like they didn't
she was an early adopter
i love that i love that um and so tell
us about what
your new job now
um so i was a newspaper reporter for
eight years and a high school teacher
for ten
um i did marketing for six and a half
years and i have just started career 4.0
working for the city of lakeland florida
in the community and economic
development department doing community
engagement
so
um what's the official title
community engagement coordinator oh how
about that community engagement like
what exactly what is that exactly like
events and stuff like
engaging with the community
the uh she bridges the gap from the
community to the city
yes
i like it
um
[Music]
she bridges the gap from the community
to the city
yes that sweet exactly i mean when you
described the the job that you were
applying for it sounded perfect for you
i have adopted a new hometown
one of the things that i'm an anomaly i
don't know it probably skipped a
generation because neither mom nor dad
particularly cared about community stuff
like
we just upped and moved all the time and
you know they were looking out for the
immediate family but they never felt any
great need to
you know make the world a better place
certainly that kind of um
the idea of non-profit or service or
whatever was never really like their jam
um but um
yeah i'm a foster parent and i
have the this invisible sucker tattoo
that every pitiful animal in the net you
know within a few miles can can detect
and they all seem to find me and i've
been pretty good at finding them homes
uh of the
13 cats i've fostered most recently 11
of them
were adopted out one passed away and we
kept one
but
i think one out of 13 ain't bad no
that's great i do not i'm not yet
officially the crazy cat lady um you're
single
i've been single for a really long time
and maybe it's you know time to think
about doing something about that but
cassie's left the nest do you have a
type that maybe this will audience will
it'll reach somebody in lakeland area
that can uh since we just recently had
mayam bialik the host of jeopardy and
steve wozniak
i mean i think that we might have been
broadening our audience of the wild ride
podcast enough to include
a few nerds who might oh maybe we have
smart people listening now
do you have a time you are smart
like the people you look for when you
get to a new school like where where are
the nerds you know where are the smart
people
nerdy's good
there's good i am a sucker for um a guy
who can play guitar okay um and sing
yeah like
anybody who can play guitar and sing
that's uh you know
yeah
there's a fast track on that great um
but uh i don't know i mean
and
you know
[ __ ] eating skills
oh my god
yeah you can just
yeah there's a whole bunch of
things to get through but i'm just
kidding
okay i'm it's like when i made the joke
about mom it's a joke
nice joke gilly
yeah he wasn't always cool like i i
i don't know i don't know that i'm
cooled down but
is it nap time
there anything that that uh
i love you so much i love you so much i
love you so much and um i was totally
gonna spill the beans on some of the
stuff that like people don't know go for
it like you're afraid of roller coasters
yeah even though i'm pretty candid about
that
i mean
your wuss cred is is pretty strong like
when we go to theme parks and stuff you
won't go on anything that dylan my
younger son
who well i mean it was really more like
cassie who's now sort of you know in
college but
but going back 10 years cassie was
i don't know i guess 10 years ago cassie
was
10.
but i remember like cassie being eight
eight years old and
and like we would go to
orlando to
you know the universal theme park and
and
i would
wait at the exit of the roller coaster
you would babysit dylan while we went on
all the thrill rides and you wouldn't
ride anything that dylan at age five
wouldn't go on if dylan was not with us
i would still be waiting at the exit of
the roller coaster i'm not getting on it
and
you have a whole stand-up bit about how
adamant you are about not being a parent
but you are [ __ ] good with kids
and your uncle skills like your uncling
i mean it's partly because you are a kid
in disguise
um but your ability not much of a
disguise
that's true that's true um but um
you know when you think back to like
swinging cass around and chill until she
would get dizzy and and walk and pass
out and like holding her and carrying
her like you have this
mushy fuzzy
like
playful uncle but also nurturing uncle
um side
and and granted your patience you want
nothing to do with diapers unless you're
putting [ __ ] on a fan and stuff like
that like
poo flying around on cameras one thing
poo in a diaper is a whole different
ball game do you ever see the the [ __ ]
stamp
you saw that like uh when cassie was a
baby i took her dirty diaper and just
smushed it on my forehead yep i remember
that and if you ever find the pregnant
cartwheel you know i want to see that
uh did that not make it into the tour
video
the pregnant cartwheel i was nine and a
half months pregnant because cass was
late okay and
googling like how do you induce labor
like we had an appointment to induce me
a couple of days later about cartwheel
to do it um a friend of steve's
um had a gymnastics coach who swore that
doing a cartwheel would bring on labor
at that point i'd gone for walks around
to the neighborhood and
spicy food and so i did two or three
cartwheels at nine and a half months
pregnant wow cassie's first stunt and
steve filmed it it still took pitocin
i think that might live in the
don't try this around volume tour or
whether it's volume two the tour video
um i don't think i've ever seen it but
yeah i'm definitely i'm definitely cindy
can call me out i'm definitely a [ __ ]
like when it comes to roller coasters
when it comes to bungee jumping i don't
like it i don't want to do it you're
smarter than people think you're not
nearly as brave as people think got near
um
which
you're not that great an actor i mean i
love you and you're really good on
camera and your presence and your timing
and all of that is fantastic
um
and and certainly like your ability
to to be filmed
but you cannot pretend and and like
inhabit a character who's very different
from yourself
and i think i think i stand a chance of
that you can go about 10 degrees to the
right or to the left of your your own
experience but
whatever yeah i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say i don't know that you could
necessarily like pretend to be somebody
very very different from yourself um
maybe you could now
but the um
because certainly at the beginning of
jackass maybe less so now
your acting chops weren't all that the
the reason
so many of those clips are funny is
because you are legitimately terrified
yeah um i mean watching a brave person
jump off a cliff
yeah is just kind of not that it's not
it's not that funny it's not that
exciting watching somebody who's scared
out of their mind but so desperate for
attention that they will do something
they absolutely loathe and despise now
there you've got some material
and the only reason so much of that is
funny is because you are scared out of
your mind um and so people were like
does your brother even feel pain like is
how did he get so brave yeah i'm like
well i might have dropped him on his
head once or twice when he was little
but he is a total like his man colds are
ridiculous he's a total wuss
and um he's not that brave like when you
see the face that's because he's
actually feeling it he's not pretending
for the camera
um
and you're so much smarter and um and
like softer and mushier than people
would think
well thank you cindy one
um
and i think
i don't know if i have anything else i
think uh this was amazing it was long
yeah i think we went with one of our
longer shows yeah how long did i 20. wow
yeah i was like feel free to trim it
like to do 50 minutes if it's a really
good podcast it's an hour to hour and 10
and this is an hour and 20.
i love you so much we didn't even talk
about my adrenaline junkie stuff but
that's i mean when we were kids you
loved roller coasters and i hated them
and early in my journalism career you
know i wanted to interview the death row
inmates and go out and like at one
o'clock in the morning and interview the
drug dealers and the prostitutes and and
stuff like that and um understand like
why they did what they did i wanted to
interview death
you guys could do it together
maybe you can get us a contact into
somebody on death row and we'll
interview him you can help us source
that
some the guys i interviewed are still
there because um
you know it's like it's a life sentence
they're not going anywhere
yeah that'd be interesting but um but
yeah like that that sort of
fascination with with crazy stuff it
certainly like it went away once i had
kids right i'm not putting myself in
harm's way or taking risks so much
anymore but
um but that you come by that honestly
too um but yeah this this was good yeah
i love it i love you thank you so much i
would not normally ask people if they
want to promote anything but i don't
think that you want to promote anything
you know what i'll promote one thing
okay i mentioned i'm a foster parent
um there is a critical shortage of
foster homes right now there were
recently a bunch of news stories about
kids having to sleep in social work
offices
there is especially a shortage of homes
for kids with special needs
teens and sibling groups
and
if anybody has ever like had it in their
heart or thought about maybe you know
you've got a spare room maybe your kids
are leaving the nest or
um you you've got an only child and you
know maybe a sibling would be good
i just you know it's not easy like
teenagers aren't easy
mine might have crashed the car the
other night um
but oh my gosh it is so
like
fulfilling it is so fulfilling it has
enriched my life in so many ways i
didn't know anything about special needs
before my son was born with down
syndrome and autism
but i um he has made us all
such better people um you know our joke
is be more like dill he's our little
life coach
um the world would be a better place if
everybody knew how to just be like dill
so i would say
my plug
is
take a class like they're online they're
usually about three weeks
in
florida there are uh there's hardly you
can't take a class to become a foster
parent yes because before anybody will
place a child with you you have to be
licensed and in order to be licensed you
take a class and then there's a home
study and one time once you are licensed
and do take on foster children they
actually give you money to to do that
yeah the state covers the care of the
kids um a lot of the kids are available
for adoption
um
and uh
it's just it is so important and
so many of these kids man they didn't do
anything to deserve the crap that you
know has come their way
and um i know that uh
you know i'm a parent of five now i got
five names on my necklace i hatched two
i've acquired three others through my
unofficial into that official fostering
journey um i'm not done
but um it's so important so um
yeah maybe we'll throw up a link for
just you know find the foster care
agency in your area
and there's no
risk involved really to start by taking
the class
and then you know exploring
find out about it and once people get
licensed you can start with respite care
where you just do you know a week or two
with a kid
um who are in transition they have
somewhere to go but you're a stop
but um
it's it's really important you know
there are a lot of people fostering pets
but there are not as many fostering
humans
um
so that's like the next step the respite
is it goes big brother big sister
program and then respite and then foster
and then maybe adoption but yeah i mean
there's um it's not the same step for
everybody right um
and um
you know there
you and i both believe occasionally that
that there's a greater power that puts
people in your path at the right time
for the right reason
and um
you know if you believe that then
there's a pretty good chance that the
right kid who you're meant to
carry
the next leg of the journey is gonna
cross your path and um
you can open yourself up to that
possibility so i love it that's my plug
it's a great plug and you're a great
guest and you're a great sister and i
love you so much and i'm so proud of you
thank you
all right [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah feel free
to cut that sucker down
no way i wish we did more like these paw
hates cutting [ __ ] down
yeah dude
my people those of you who stick around
to the very end i call you the street
team
because way back in the beginning after
every episode i always said
uh please post uh a screenshot of
something or other and and uh tag the
guest and you know let him know and
you know let him feel the love
and that was sort of my sneaky way of
trying to get everybody to promote the
podcast and you know a lot of you did
and i've always been so grateful for
that and i love it so much when i'm on
tour and people come up to me and they
say street team there's different things
people say they say street team they say
it's the age of the selfie and the crazy
crazy
diehards they say i'm your second
biggest fan it's just all super fun
stuff and i love you guys
and thank you so much for sticking
around through a hundred episodes
let's go